cancel culture ain't new
cancel culture ain't freaking new it is
some old ass [ __ ] i'm going to stand up
for this podcast
there's some old-ass [ __ ] it's been
going on for a while
they've tried to come at uh quite a few
people
um we've seen what happened to andrew
recently
and um
who have they been successful with
they've they've uh
cancelled
well they canceled the president of the
united states
that was uh pretty impressive
um you'd think of all people you
wouldn't get canceled if you were
president but boom
you got social media taken away alex
jones milo
stefan molyneux
entertain
there's probably a bunch of others but
it's not new you know it's been going on
for a while like um
trying to remove
voices um
doesn't silence them okay trying to move
ideas
doesn't get rid of them all it does is
it proves the accuracy of those concepts
if we're being honest okay
um
like look did alex jones go away
as far as i know he's still around um
most of these people are still out and
about you know donald trump is still
claiming he's going to be running for
president so
whether he does or he doesn't i don't
know i mean
i think that that guy's days are over
for being honest he kind of had his
opportunity and he screwed it up
um who's the
who's that new guy that that seems to be
getting a lot of traction uh
desantis
right he seems he seems like an
interesting candidate for a presidential
switch over from
demented
asleep joe
somebody shared a
clip the other day
i saw on twitter and the caption was
something like i don't know when the
edible kicks in and he's sitting there
after signing something and he's like he
doesn't know where he is and he's kind
of like he just passes the pen over to a
random dude he's shaking the hands of
people that aren't there
man the world's a strange place
but yeah cancel culture right so
um
they'll they'll try to remove you when
they don't like what you say
um i've
let me share a couple stories with you
actually um
i don't know if i've mentioned this
publicly
much or before on the channel i i've
probably talked about it privately with
a couple of my bros
but um
so
back in my debt business around 2010
the canadian dollar was at par with the
us dollar
and um there were some legislative
changes that happened in the u.s about a
year two before that and what ended up
happening was a lot of the american
companies saw an opportunity to not
promote their services in a country that
didn't have the same legislation as what
was in the us so they started basically
running the same advertising campaigns
that got them in so much trouble in the
us a few years prior
i was i was i was the largest canadian
player at that time
but there were a lot of american
companies with uh very deep pockets you
know the u.s marketplace is quite a bit
bigger than uh canada's
and they started purporting the same
sort of uh promises hopes and dreams to
uh canadian citizens and they and they
flat out lie like they would say things
like you know there's a new government
program sort of thing which is one of
the catch phrases which really caught
their attention so credit card companies
banks and even media personalities and
the government got behind
writing new legislation to cancel
the industry that i was operating in
and the process took about
two and a half three years i would say
and they were successful in getting the
legislation passed um and implementing
it
and they legitimately canceled an entire
industry
which for the most part the ones that
were operating above board were very
very helpful
in eliminating debt improving credit
ratings helping people get back on their
feet uh incredibly helpful in fact but
that just showed me like that was one of
the red pilling moments for me that was
like a a big
unplugging moment for me
and uh
i was like holy [ __ ] like you can be
doing the right thing you can save
people a lot of money you can lead them
down a brighter path you can improve the
credit rating but
the credit card companies in the banks
had so much power so much influence that
um
regulators just said oh okay you know
let's do this because this should be
better
and they don't think
one of the things i learned about
government at that time because i went
down to queen's park for about two and a
half years i was leading this trade
organization and um i dealt with
lobbyists we had to hire lobbyists we
spent 60 grand on lobbyists and stuff
like that and i'm meeting all the policy
makers and regulators canadians uh
watching the stream will know the name
jagmeet singh because he's the leader of
the ndp party here and he was the critic
to the bill
um which was called i think bill 55 at
the time and i met with jagmeet singh
several times and he's not the person
on um screen that
he holds himself out to be you know to
care about people and um you know the
little guy and that sort of stuff uh and
i experienced the same thing with all
the others that i met as well
they're more concerned with
their positions their ten-year
their seat in office and stuff like that
they don't really care about what's good
for the little guys so that was another
big red pilling moment for me so when
they tried to cancel the industry and
were successful at it pretty much
everybody had to shut down and fold
i'm not a dummy and i've got a great
lawyer and we went through the
legislation there's no point in trying
to fight legislation was another outcome
of that so we went through all the
legislation and we found a carve out
that was suitable and we pivoted and
survived most people don't
survive canceling
most industries most companies
they just don't it's very very difficult
if nearly impossible
you haven't seen alex jones back on
mainstream social media
i don't think donald trump's got
anything back he went and created his
own social media platform
um
what are their names out there miley
annopolis has kind of disappeared in the
woodwork
and i guess we'll you know we'll see
what happens with um andrew um as far as
his cancellation i mean
um
most google guy on the planet at one
point i i checked on google trends i've
got a shortcut for google trends because
i always keep an eye on
you know what's trending out there and i
think i compared uh
tate versus
kim kardashian versus joe rogan versus
elon musk like i tried to think of some
big names and
he's right you know there were there
were more searches trending than any of
those other names
he got caught up in the whirlwind of all
that and canceled culture came
and they want because they own the
platforms they own the distribution of
media
a few years ago i had um
i had a tweet that went out that went
really viral that um got picked up on
morning shows stuff like um i don't
think it went on the view but like
morning shows around the world like that
you know where it's a bunch of women
sitting around the table talking about
stuff and they'll find like sound bites
and clips and there's a tweet that i put
out
and ended up on a whole bunch of uh
pieces of um
like media outlets and stuff like that
there's a tweet that said something
along the lines of um you know ladies if
you want to keep a guy be feminine uh be
beautiful have culinary skills just
basic stuff you know stuff that
you know your grandmothers would have
been told telling like their
great-granddaughters or their
granddaughters you know 50 years ago or
something like that uh nothing
outrageous and they tried to cancel me
it was it was really funny because
um
i got this
this message from my office
and um they were
they were basically coming up and going
like oh is this richard cooper the guy
that works at total debt freedom sort of
thing you know i was like
so like i founded the business 20 years
ago what are you gonna try to they
legitimately try to cancel me they
legitimately try to cancel me for my own
company which i thought was hilarious um
so that brings me to anti-fragility
actually
since um that's an important concept
here
uh what's mike said here camilla harris
would get destroyed in an election i
don't know
i don't know about the state of
elections man it's like
it's a real funny thing
oh man yeah but anti-fragility is really
really important so
um
there's a concept of fragility
robustness and anti-fragility um got
this from a book called anti-fragile i
actually did a book review this was
around the time when i was doing book
reviews on
my channel um i should
there's there's so many good books out
there um
anyway i see these book reviews and i
did one on anti-fragile there's a video
on my channel i think it was in the m3
at the time
and these three concepts of
anti-fragility robustness and fragility
fragility is basically if like if i take
i don't have anything glass here but if
i were to take a
a glass cup and drop it on the floor it
would probably shatter that's that's
fragile
um most things in the world are either
fragile or robust robustness is taking
like a bag of sand if i take a bag of
sand and i drop it on the floor nothing
happens to it it doesn't break it
doesn't get worse it doesn't get better
nothing happens to it and then there's a
concept of anti-fragility
anti-fragility is when you apply chaos
to something and it actually improves
um so when the
uh financial institutions the credit
card companies the government came for
um my industry around 2010 and passed
the legislation a few years later
my business became anti-fragile because
it improved to the point where the
legislation basically removed the
competitors the change in the economic
landscape with the value of the canadian
versus the us dollar change things and
they either went out of business they
sold their book a business they
some pivoted not very many but most
didn't didn't actually improve
uh my business was one of the few that
actually improved so anti-fragility
looks like that anti-fragility looks
like applying chaos to something and it
gets better so
in regards to our friend the top g um an
example of anti-fragility is if he
actually gets better um
i watched that uh was it the final word
or a final word from tate the other day
um
how can i put this
it was an interesting video to watch
because it was totally different from
all the um interviews and the uh tic toc
clips and all that sort of stuff one of
the things i like about andrew is
he takes
ownership
he takes it
extreme
ownership i think is the best way to put
it i think jocko wellness you know uses
the same phrase but it's like you know
one of the things he said was something
along the lines if i got struck by
lightning i would i would take the blame
for that
and you know if you think about that for
a second are you the kind of person that
would blame the weather are you the kind
of person that would blame
mother nature
whatever it may be or are you the kind
of person that would look in the mirror
and say
that was stupid why did i go outside
during an electrical storm
with an umbrella or with a golf club
standing up or something like that or
standing under a very tall tree for
example
that would be your fault
and he's right
not many people take extreme ownership
in that sense so there's a few things
that i liked about that um video that he
did i like
you say that you're um
a victim of your own success
and
i guess he's right because
you're um your entire affiliate network
network was what created the um the
reach you know got you the uh trending
page of um
google uh
for your name and all those clips were
made and the vast majority of those
clips i mean if we're being honest they
had the hu affiliate link in them from
what i saw um some of them were taken
out of context but the vast majority
were from that program
so
the the the cancellation and the uh you
know the movement into the next chapter
um what does it call it uh step two
um you know version 2.0 or
through photo wherever he happens to be
that that next step will be like the um
you know
like like sunlight distills all you know
if you don't mean like it sanitizes all
the [ __ ] and then it's like you know
you can't hide in any shadows when
you're in you know the direct sunlight
so it's like okay well
this is where you get to
and there's a lot going on right now
with the mano swamp
the red pill
um men's self-improvement self-help sort
of notions
and it's not new hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you